what up reject nation greg and john here
today to watch the boys season three
episode two yeah had to pack up a little
bit more it's the last week here or move
to the new place but guys if you can
check us out on patreon become a super
sexy reject today full length watch
alongs for the boys are over there along
with a bunch of other shows that we
cover at the same tier reaction
highlights and watch alongs included if
you can't do that because you want to be
a meanie not pledge money if you want to
do that leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated and your thoughts on the
episode down below also subscribe and
click that notification bell to notify
when our next reaction for the boys is
up here on the channel gotta thank them
boys at prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights and please another
friendly reminder this is the boys so
anything with like graphic
nerd
and saying that word youtube is like why
would you say that yeah they're gonna
have to be blurred out all right or else
this will be not just limited ad wise it
could be limited just in viewership-wise
it's a certain country
why won't it play so yeah guys just a
little friendly reminder the record some
people complain about that but anywho
let's get to it
we can offer you
a family
[Music]
mr adana tell me the truth
are you having me followed
i am afraid
that you
have become a toxic personality dip oh
no
left me no choice
but to run
put a cork in it zayn brought to you by
lean lighty frozen dinners by vaughn
simulcast live across vbs vtv vnn vaut
soul and vatimundo join me for my annual
birthday spectacular oh god for sonic
the cast of riverdale
and of course
the cast of river dude that's right man
they they love homelanders
you really going to shoot that [ __ ] in
your veins you know
i think i just might oh my god well i'll
get one more for less i don't think
you're gonna do it
yeah wasted no time that's a new low
even for you oh i can go lower i can go
straight too well
butcher you have to stop
please
for becca
oh my god his actual brother
she's dead
[Music]
huey the canary
are you mad at me
no
of course not
look
hear your mother's son and i'll always
watch out for you
all right
you don't want to piss off that little
kid man that's your last link to
humanity hey there sleepyhead rise and
shine big day
anything a little extra special about
today
what oh it's birthday
[Laughter]
how could you forget
what if we tell butcher we tell butcher
i've been a soup sidekick for a year oh
christ he's never going to not torture
me for this is he
no no no look we can
handle this ourselves all right i
wouldn't do that that song was gross
when i was 18. i sing it now they're
gonna make me keep a thousand feet from
schools
and don't sing it it's easy for you to
say you're already in the seven i don't
want to make waves
trust me
egg waves supersonic waves your real uh
contender on american hero
keep it up we could be teammates oh wow
i hope so sir of course it doesn't hurt
that the show's judge used to get come
drunk on your chorizo picante
[Music]
he knew it was coming sir we're loading
the prom troopers oh that will wink
i got to admit
i was a little unsure about this
but now honestly i am just so excited
about what's coming
really
that's good star of a beautiful
friendship i've got this for you
you and your dad can build it together
523 pieces of family fun
french and camigo is starting with the
crimson compass and i'm gonna hit up
gunpowder his soldier point
you could close the book on him once and
for all
for your dad
your family [ __ ] off with that [ __ ]
oh
i might have one thing
[Music]
how's that grin
inclusive kingdom
brave mape's inclusive kitchen
and veggie tacos
oh no if you want to wait three hours
for a three minute ride it is a
monumental monster
since when
okay first work then pleasure
well how much more friendship looks in
shape
yeah
he used those values to prove america's
exceptionalism to the
[Music]
[Laughter]
he helped guide america
[Music]
i love that she's enjoying this so much
is that a healthier way to take your
medication
you seem a little old
we're youngest hearts
oh sweetie can't you talk
would you like to hear something new
[Music]
oh no
okay sarah mclaughlin on
[Laughter]
[Music]
how did he died who killed him
talk the show is the truth [ __ ]
he died a hero
[Music]
it's not very inclusive
[Music]
oh no
well this escalated quickly those poor
kids
how frequently does that happen here
they can't cry
give me the v24
500
peanut butter and blood
hey you got your blood in my peanut
butter
we're gonna need a little more jfk just
got rimmed out by marilyn version
it's got to fit with the routine
actually show the routine
you're gonna [ __ ] love this
that's your backup
this is a juvenile attempt to get me to
look like a sex doll
instead of a co-captain why don't you
lighten the [ __ ] up ready let's hit it
if starlight doesn't want to sing she
doesn't sing oh
stan
a rebranding
so listen we start with the docu-series
from vots soul
a train
to africa boom
the arts
it'll trace his family's journey from
the plains of africa all the way
to yeah like i want to get back in touch
with my roots
like in roots
and for the gen z's a state-of-the-art
interactive learning experience
oh wow
is that a video game about the slave
trade some powerful stuff
it's really something
um i'm sorry you said you don't get many
potential parents
well you know what kind of a home we are
right yeah no of course it's a group
home
oh my god bright burn academy
had a home like this in boys diabolical
hey can you can you uh can you show me
the rest of the place oh okay
sorry what uh what is it teddy
[Music]
oh
hey wait a minute i know you
yeah he's right there on the tv
starlight is is the one that sent me
here i'm completely sterile we just want
to keep it about love and not publicity
this is fantastic with a superhuman
mother there is far less chance of
parental fatality
you mind if i uh just kind of flip
around a bit thank you thank you sorry
sorry
is there anything in particular that
you're looking for um boy girl
you know we don't really see gender that
way well samir is south asian
that is very hot right now
oh golly right samir right here okay
south asian
unplugging it makes you lose all the
data
we're getting to eject
[Music]
parental fatality nadia do you know why
you're here today
did i do something wrong
not at all
you're getting what you've always wanted
you're adopting me no i can't adopt you
sport
oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna take care of you
no good very bad
[Laughter]
anything in the news still nothing
this is fascinating a cleaning crew
sterilized the site within 15 minutes of
the incident no witnesses have come
forward and if they do we'll deal with
them
the same way you dealt with tony
come on sport haven't i always taken
care of you
[Music]
this is stan edgar's season here
next
there you go
nice piece
welcome
next
[Laughter]
gunpowder time
yeah i've followed you since your
payback days
14 years old picked to be soldier boy
sidekick who's a great man you must have
been chuffed eh letting him watch you on
the bog stick his finger up your bum a
bit give him a sloppy little nosh
now
all i want to know
is what happened to him
now you're gonna tell me maybe i put a
bullet in your head
soldier boy never touched me like that
oh you just beat the crap out of you
[Music]
oh damn
whoa
that's an amazing eyesight there butcher
oh no time to guess i'll be 28
oh
there's really that's yeah
no music
[Music]
it feels like i see that terminator 2.
so there's a little blue light yeah
[Music]
oh my god damn
smart
[Music]
it's your lucky day but considering
you're my annual birthday save
gift
to throw yours away and be a real slap
in the lord's face don't you think
you don't want to go to hell for all
eternity
i'm
jewish
well regardless just step back from the
ledge please
oh [ __ ]
come on look i'm here now if you jump
i'm just gonna fly down and save you
anyway it's all futile and
oh wow
oh no
oh whoa what a weird irony
it's my birthday
[Music]
oh
my god damn it
don't snap man please
continue saving this poor young woman
how is it fair that you get saved while
a beautiful perfect
god
i think you should jump
i don't think i want to
jump please i
i just want to get down
anymore
you are so sick
[Music]
no god
no god
[ __ ] did she bite off her own tongue
storm for a million dollar baby herself
[Music]
wow
wow damn that was pretty sick
that
took a turn
i'm sorry i mean you're missing work
your hand a lot going on
there's something i should know
just make it about starlight i'm trying
to help i don't always need your help i
mean you don't have to treat me like i'm
a kid yeah i was thinking that i was
treating you like my boyfriend well you
know this is actually none of my
business
excellent cover
cut her some slack
you shouldn't be afraid of a powerful
woman
[Music]
my god
all right thanks for the save
by the way yeah that was really good
role play
oh um
i may have signed us up to adopt a child
[Laughter]
season four
it's like soldier boys like this
this still sliver inside of my brain
after he
i don't know what to do
you need to go back to butcher
wow
what a different season
please don't tell janine about this
i just want to leave her out of it
janine will be right here
waiting
stay safe for her hmm
to get monique's support they needed to
break up
last missing piece
hi buddy i'm sorry i'm running late
i thought i'd have time to sneak in a
haircut
just wanted to tell you that i love you
and i'll see you soon so
i love you and i'll see you soon
he's really good at those brick films
canary
i'll nature
things are good
ryan's good
i should leave it well enough alone
before i go and [ __ ] it all up
newman's a soup
she's the head popper
oh [ __ ]
if we're gonna take them down
we have to do whatever it takes
we have to do it your way
[Laughter]
this would be 24 time
oh you poor pathetic soap too doesn't
have the shape-shifter guy anymore
and oh my god he took it he took it you
got to be [ __ ] kidding me get your
ass off of my car why are you protecting
soulja boy
[Laughter]
oh
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
like turbine
[Music]
[Music]
don't kill him butcher in [ __ ] 84 but
i didn't see it happen you must have
seen something i didn't see [ __ ]
we're working with the cia
who's your case officer grace oh
no
oh [ __ ] damn it i told you everything i
know all right please just just
but it don't change
what you are
wow
wow
[Music]
and now it'll look like homelander did
it happy birthday homeland thank you
i can see your girl you disgusting fat
[ __ ]
get off the [ __ ] stage
you're not she died
we all make mistakes right come on no
give
no no
no
this is so awkward i don't make mistakes
i'm not just like the rest of you
i'm stronger i'm smarter
i'm better
i am better
[Laughter]
whole life rich people powerful people
try to muzzle me cancel me
keep me impotent and obedient like i'm a
[ __ ] puppet is todd gravitated
towards this todd's loving this
i am the only one who possibly can
you're not the real heroes
i'm the real earth oh you crazy man
wow staring out to darkness
the mic dropped jesus
that season something else
something else the no [ __ ] season
absolute vodka
huh
did you say something
i love this show
it is pretty great
it is pretty great
it's pretty
unsettling
but great
yes i mean it's one of my favorite shows
ever made it
it's definitely one of like my all-time
favorite shows i
i love everything they're doing there's
not a single
complaint thus far
i really don't i think i think like i
watched the season one and two a couple
months ago and then to come back here
and it's just i just love
where we've chose
i think they i don't know if they took
into consideration how people were kind
of responsive to the first three
episodes of season two initially because
i think that actually works really
strong
um when you watch it immediately after
season one
and but this feels like a sequel season
as opposed to picking up moments later
and
just everything they're just flipping so
much around and they're they're getting
past the [ __ ] of like prolonged
buildup it's like just enough build up
because we've had so much buildup with
homelander already
revealing himself to the public of who
and what he really is like
he does have this thwarted ideology of
himself and what he is that he he does
have this own like
self-grandiose god-like image that he he
thinks he fancies himself to be
you know while also knowing that he is
just a child at heart this broken child
uh
so exposing that and then going after
vaude the people that control him it's
like he got pushed to this point and you
think stan edgar would get to a point
where he would realize that you know or
like yeah maybe maybe i'm pushing this a
little too harsh
yeah if this is at least evolve even if
i have leverage and control to some
degree over him this is a volatile
substance and dealing with liable to
snap and do something horrible at any
moment because he's represent he's he's
seen homelander many times already go i
don't want to listen
everyone's name that i'm blanking on i
can't remember elizabeth's shoes
character name
oh what's the one name i can't remember
golly ah it'll come to me
it's right there
oh yeah what is her name i remember uh
i can almost i can almost taste it i
forget i forget what it is
here at the moment i'll look it up later
um but i remember it's elizabeth's shoe
but even with elizabeth chu the one who
had the most uh influence over him
he would rebel against her and she had
to like do all kinds of things just to
keep him happy
you know
and you'd think that stan edgar would
have a little bit of foresight to be
like maybe
i need to
not push as far because not all of san
agra small like really obviously the
tipping point is the death of stormfront
a woman who he
like
clearly loved i think that's such a
great
starting point for this season because
it's so not just a physical thing
whatsoever like even
destroyed obliterated uh he's still it's
always been this emotional comfort you
know like even though she's all messed
up
uh in the in
in her own little um
at-home hospital bed yeah
she's
he still like she gets off on her and
then he still connects to her still
loves her
so to be that heartbroken and and then
just to get to this [ __ ] point you
know like ever it doesn't matter anymore
like it just doesn't matter that does
the the one last person alive yeah
who
he thought accepted him yeah you know
who could maybe get through to him in
some way
and so he had to be at the push of the
breaking point here just mind-blowing
he's got
great scenes here because he's just been
getting slowly stripped down over the
course of the last three seasons and
then to kick it off here where you know
like that that scene where he convinces
that girl that at least the way they
they edit it like he could have done a
little something he could do like like a
little
whole clap thing create some type of
force generating power there's things
the homelander could have done to push
her
um but i could see that he just forced
her to jump
and uh that is a that was like such a
great scene and it's like a such a
messed up twisted scene but so well
written and so well performed anthony
starr is brilliant
and uh the way they've been carrying
over
mother's milk marvin's storyline
because they hinted at it he had seen
that road trip moment when they're
uncovering who stormfront is
in season two where he unveils his past
about his dad
and then
now bringing it to this point
where he's been trying to let it go but
the thing that kept him motivated to
take down supes was always that core
memory of losing his father
and i like what they're doing with him
because
he
he's always been so
they pointed out in season two he's he's
so ocd
that's a big part of him and he and he's
always the one in the group who seems to
be the most
in control of him himself and the most
level-headed yeah sure he could lose his
cool and whatever but he knows how to
ground himself back to center faster
than everyone else
and then to have him here where he is
he's just lost it he's losing it he
can't control himself yeah and then i
have the flip with the wife uh
now support him when in the past couple
seasons it's been
never supportive of this path aids all
right i'm really i'm really digging it a
lot but john there's so much to unpack
uh newman edgar
starlight take it away john sure yeah no
i've been loving the season thus far as
well i think they've got a really nice
gradual pace and i think one of the
things
about that i mean everything you just
said absolutely and then you know with
with huey and newman and starlight you
know we saw the ads and we're like oh
damn like they're that thing he said in
this episode about you know i thought
that we could do it the legit way and we
can't we have to do it your way butcher
you know i i remember people be like
it's kind of like you know kind of a
revealing scene to show even though we
know it's gonna get to that point and
then to have that be like a moment from
pretty early on
is just one of those ear marks and i'm
like okay good like yeah yeah because
one thing i've admired thus far about
this season is that they don't
uh you know dilly dally with you know
breaking some kind of
advancement in terms of the stakes or
the tension or if there's a secret or if
there is
some kind of sensitive situation or
piece of information that's going to
come to a head and we are not going to
draw out that tension we're going to
walk right into that conflict
and uh and so yeah i think they they do
nicely in this show to make it not as
much like yeah there are big reveals and
there are these big moments that are
really distinct and unsettling but it's
also about how to deal with those
in an ever unfolding situation where
it's like you can't just make one split
decision and now we know and now we
better take out newman it's like i gotta
huey has to maintain his cover and
starlight also has this weird sort of
back and forth where she thinks she's in
a position to do some actual good within
the system but is also working outside
the system against the system
and so yeah i think there's a lot that's
going to become very fascinating about
that because not only are they good at
yes like subverting everything we know
about soups but they're also good at
kind of surprising you
with different nuances and things and i
feel like there's certainly more of that
ahead for newman there's probably
more to that than meets the eye and
they're also just really great at
drawing out those really twisted
circumstances finally getting that
glimpse in of like okay she was
essentially not not exactly per his
admission but essentially adopted by
stan edgar and made into his
pseudo-daughter and now
you know even though that relationship
seems like there is something legitimate
in there it's also clearly like a power
structural arrangement as well it's like
jack nicholson and matt damon in the
department
yeah yeah exactly and it's that stuff i
think that they do really nicely to
blend the things that are so crazy and
high concept than with the things that
are all too familiar to how
just you know trouble and deceit
and conniving uh you know movers in
society operate and so yeah i think the
way that they've managed to take that
sort of oh [ __ ] moment of the end of the
season of like oh damn it's the last
season of damn it's it's newman and
huey's walking right into the lion's den
i think they've done nicely to walk
around in that and to make it clear that
that situation is gonna explode but
there's other stuff in the foreground
happening first and i think that makes a
nice kind of rounded thing with
everything to do with soldier boy over
here that has felt like yeah it's what
butchered the boys are doing but now
it's finally converging with huey's
story and huey's uh dealings with newman
and you have to assume that there's
probably some kind of deeper connection
maybe between
her and soldier boy or those situations
might overlap in some way like they're
good at making this machine or this this
you know they're good at laying out a
story in a way that feels very alive and
feels like there's so many different
moving parts and it is you know this
sort of strange and unnerving just world
that you're plopped into and i think the
acting has been top notch
and yeah just the way they've advanced
the story so far has felt really smooth
and really graceful from the start of
the season to hear
and i hope beyond i think i mean if i
were to
quickly gather a prediction of soldier
boys that i imagine they couldn't
control him yeah so they had to freeze
him yeah
because they can't actually kill him
yeah
and i love the build-up they're doing on
that too is because we have seen images
of him in the promos and we have seen
footage of him within universe thus far
but of all the things to have building
the most gradual i love that they're
taking their time with that because it
does
you know it hypes you up for like when
we can really get gents and knuckles in
with everybody but also i think for the
story
it really nicely balances out everything
else they've chosen to do
yeah there's a lot of great things that
they're doing here and i think
especially with butcher what this
see is kind of what i felt with the
trailers and i feel like this episode
just solidifies it that much more is
that for many in this season it's
breaking point season this is everyone's
breaking point
you know like uh early on
um huey is now
like
i can't do this anymore this is i broke
the jam i broke the jam this is the
point now this is the point where i have
to embrace the path that butcher always
went for because clearly there's no way
to to move forward with things butcher
doing something he would never do and
now he's taking b-24s so that way he can
you know go up against the supes i also
think that scene
that action scene was
really tense you don't really get action
scenes like that in the boys and i
remember
it in season two there's like one with
kimiko and her brother on the street
that didn't have music and they just let
it really sit in the tension but nothing
quite like this or um where you got to
re you get to visually realize this
almost deadshot meets
wanted
like
type of uh gunfu fight scene and when i
really gun foo but a good gun fight
scene
uh and i thought that was just so
tension filled and didn't rely on on
music or hyper kinetic camera work
throughout except for that one really
cool shot where they revealed it where
he he does the
domino effect of where the bullet will
bounce to which was scary like how do
you fight this guy yeah you know and it
seemed like the you know it works off
sound so that's why i had like he had to
throw him off his senses by doing that
which i thought was great so um yeah i
thought like that was awesome and
butcher being pushed to the point where
you know he's listening to that audio
with ryan and and you know hearing
becca's voice and going and i believed
him when he was like this is it
and and so much it's such a great flip
because they are constantly flipping
things because huey's constantly like we
can't do this i don't want to be a part
of this we got to get out of this and
then butcher is reeling him back in all
the time
and then now here
um butcher's like i'm ready to put this
away and huey reels him in yeah so it's
a cool
switcheroo of what they're they're
messing with the dynamics a lot yeah
there's a lot of great twists on the
different motivations and the different
ways characters approach the situations
everyone's kind of on opposite terms
yeah i really love this uh i think what
they're doing this direction is solid
the supersonic stuff is fine like i'm
not really imagine it's going to amount
to something more interesting hopefully
they that boys usually
satisfies me in that direction when i'm
like it's whatever um that's fine and uh
the thing that was really surprising to
me is todd with the black wife
you know yes because clearly they're
they're making the play on and like i
know the people involved you can see
them on social media and their political
opinions are very much out there they're
very vocal uh what they think and uh
yeah you know it's it's like
the to have this the person
because the homelander still is
associated with stormfront while his
speech was not
directly about you know
the storm front point of view yeah
it's definitely gonna be feeding into
the crowd
the potential for radicalization yeah
and it's so it's a perfectly eerie
moment just eerie enough when it's like
damn that's that guy's helping raise
mm's daughter that's not good oh
well the influence is superheroes to
just anyone with like a celebrity power
position yeah i know
yeah i'm out of influence it's crazy
it's crazy stuff i think this is a
really
potent season so far
and we've only just begun that's the
crazy part to me like it's just the
beginning absolutely and they're
introducing these payback players
and of course going to get the jensen
knackles thing over time and and
they already got so much else going on
you know yeah well it's one it's one
rare example i think of a season that
starts you know so every now and again
shows will do that where it's like okay
this time all of our main ensemble are
kind of scattered around some of them
are together but some of them are you
know often different corners and it's
not the kind of situation where i'm like
come on just get them back together
already like everything is still
interesting regardless of who's
where on which team working how right
now i don't think they needed to release
this three at a time i know it's like
these are each one of these is so funny
it's so satisfying it's so great
individually and they feel so
well-rounded yeah it's because the show
premiered when it first debuted all at
once so they are stuck with a certain
level of we have to we got to do
something we got to do some type of
binge
here's the first three it's the first
three because that's a crisp number even
though i thought the first one was like
wonderful like it was wonderful and and
it didn't feel
incomplete like i don't feel like or
season two i get the feeling of no you
kind of need to watch the first three
yeah yeah then the table is set yeah
both of these ones yeah i've been
sitting here going i can't wait to come
back next week
and like it's cool not to have to for
these first few but i feel like yeah
they have really found a way to make it
very nicely episodic while also very
engrossingly binge-worthy yeah this is
uh this is wonderful stuff i'm really
i'm really digging it a lot and uh more
thoroughly satisfied great so far
what do you guys think leave your
thoughts down below and uh we will talk
with you all soon thank you for being
here